hi guys I'm Gregory are we doing this
now yeah
what's happening okay hi hello my name
like a longer name more than authoress
yeah ask Dantas oh my god I'm on Sesame
Street
yeah how tears it Morgan and Ashley you
go to their Channel
Maia pens you Morrigan on Instagram
Ashley and nur on Instagram both limited
on bikini photos but they're still
pretty to look at in the face or go to
their Instagram Robert Ellis August Sun
first want to request this hi Robert
the force awakens a fat lip reading yeah
Mark Hamill as han Solo Oh as you guys
know han Solo famously played by
Harrison Ford thank you I love Star Wars
do you why I don't really not a totally
hot forward let's not do this debate
right now a lot of stuff the Internet
[Music]
I still may be Alicia hit me right with
my face hey Ricky
hold up you know Ricky is a demon
machine and if he keeps shooting okay I
will add to David this morning I wanted
a frappe they wouldn't make it do
something coming up on the front it's
not important to get a threat what it
makes me happy to do here's with a rush
be something that makes you happy
[Music]
Santa vagrant
six kittens in a bag of water want to
stay this disgusting
are you serious the mood is so freakin
wound and I'm monkey here's a mess just
very hairy
oh yeah like that then believe it play
we oughtta hang up tonight you're not
gonna cry now
okay I'll be over there's the barge
being carry on this ship rock solid
- I'll eat your fries coming back just
tore the boat
[Music]
a juice bar no drinks whatever weird
girl it will be great if we can play
with what kissy bids I always have real
funky breath I wonder what you smell
like okay slow cinnamon something puts
the motion
[Music]
[Music]
learn how to speak anybody understand
what he says some kind of stupid accent
I think she wanted to ruin yeah we could
hear you
I think Robert stole his sister's
trinkets he's embarrassed easily did
actually I think you said tomorrow's
this birthday happy birthday to me that
loser ninjas teach you say ninja oh damn
karate can snatch your [ __ ] coheeries
I'm scared now right go pluck out our
eyelids wait could you still fall asleep
how it goes your first words I got you
good oh yeah I know I tried to make
chocolate shoes why because the guys are
told me most likely pleats in an L
position listen babe you know I need
that puppet bird I think you'd better
run along before it gets dark
you know I can see your dad Oh
[Music]
there the kitchen yeah be ready good did
that shop having a food right or like a
cool palpable or maybe a bacon flute why
is your neck wet I don't want to relive
it
they got a sick box on sale hahahahaha
even wrote an ugly
- your bird
[Music]
it's a finger puppet as you can see I
never painted it we've give it to you
but you never toasted Birds okay no why
should have told her to get rocks
[Music]
ah Vulcan my urine see that one the
seagulls stop now
that was so funny to watch it work
amusing idea mark Hamill's impression of
Harrison Ford is pretty [ __ ] spot on
the head yeah that was very I didn't I
didn't expected I know he can do like a
great voice of the Joker but I know you
could do like impressions of the
Harrison Ford it's really not good yeah
I like to think I have a natural
Harrison Ford voice you have very like
you have good voice bad way it's like
really deep and manly there yeah we got
a real compliment in it yeah yeah you
know you're gonna like your radio well
it's not like a man leave it actually
words to it
I appreciate so many ways that you do
not like your voice tone thank you this
whole I just want to come to them and
then I'm receiving what I typically do
remember like nighttime duper rare to
Holika like a deep voice even if you
like a lot of guys like your boyfriend I
would be proud of it she's dating Spy
Kids 3d super still on a boy band part
my favorite part of this bad liberating
was Carrie Fisher with monkeys yeah yeah
oh my god I laugh so hard if I was going
to cry and so of it I forget because I
saw this movie a while ago like I forget
what they were actually saying there is
this I am the actual I swear they
remember something like to bit their
lips so perfectly I know it's amazing
how long it must take to do that and
like yeah but like time-consuming it is
too like
you're out what exactly can go there
yeah it works because you can't just
like you can't just put in like words
because they're trying to make a scene
yeah yeah well having a dialogue go back
in born sorry my issues that you're a
monkey in yeah sure I like my dancing
you're the monkey yeah I like that one
too words yeah this overtime like
heading on him
what's this scene I don't notice it
always the Chewbacca getting the whole
nurse lady scanned I don't know but I
understand his vitals with one of those
bio scanners from this our son now that
makes sense I just don't I don't
remember this at all either it works so
I also like the one about ninjas the
best ones are the ones of Harrison Ford
oh that was the best moment I love what
they did with the record kylo Ren make
yeah the record and they're kind of
making it like a creepy serial killer
because he's creepy
he's very creepy and he takes that
helmet off and you're like who to people
what record is he put on when he does
that I don't think he really did it was
there no record
I don't think records exist he was like
I don't remember what he had the puppet
when he was talking on Han Solo I you
were dying I'm everywhere we're all
right Star Wars to it it's better to
watch it with like things you actually
like no one like yeah yes true I haven't
seen you laugh that hard ever no
research on would I love a lot you yeah
yeah but you like you got are going good
with it like this video I put together
or it is really funny my son and amber
and I just thought I'd forget to get all
the voices and everything for it
made for me by you yeah Oh Bobby have
you guys ever dressed up for any spouses
like the Princess Leia return in the
Jedi well my good friends our sons we
both had our outfits thousands have you
ever without your narrator Mary to them
oh we've all been very significant other
or a do you're boning you guys ever done
that first like Prince Landor gold
bikini yeah no you haven't never done
that yeah I haven't done that I look
like I'm on a gym like Star Wars if I'm
okay we'll calm down people
whoa everybody very fast you didn't see
the Dark Knight in our a pleasure video
I understand she doesn't like I know
I've seen all the Star Wars movies and I
like them you don't like don't love them
yeah yeah I like that
hey no one's judging you all I'm saying
is I'm surprised you haven't done the
golden bikini if anyone ever asked you
to do it and even like yeah even though
I'm requesting that you do it has a
girl's on it for you yeah yeah let's
turn the table for many years yeah sure
nothing for real no would you definitely
like a stormtrooper
yeah like a Chewbacca no I haven't done
it though how cool would it be to have
like a I got explainer but we're talking
about cons earlier Morgan and I yeah how
cool would it be to have like lightsaber
condoms or that's like oh yeah blue
color that would be the best that was
like let's see the Schwartz is bigger
than mine have you seen yes yes exactly
I love every baseball that's Ashley's
number one Star Wars I'm gonna make
another one farther and I don't know I'm
a little nervous on it because like how
can you redo it so good yeah well is
parity the other Star Wars movies going
to come out sent
maybe I don't know more anyway a favor
we do yeah and then the light major
science or melt like a real one were you
like if you like
another lifesaver I got to the target
and it was Nixon whizzes oh but you know
like very impressive very impressive
morning bottle toy lightsaber at Target
and I'm going to dress up as somebody it
would be profound Allah in the second
one where she's being eaten by sitting
third one remember where they like
trapped in that white outfit was a white
pants that would be your that'd be your
choice I like that up and I feel like
gonna be comfy I feel like I'd be like a
good Java like a natural Java like this
I think me naked I just look like Jabba
the Hutt you know yeah Oh
Greg yeah this is me that's Ashley
here's Morgan even say that with me and
I was maybe a little bit like no no
that's John yeah we're all we're all
Star Wars consistent with my specs a
fear I like it I survived all I think
you're most like c-3po out of anyone I
met thank you you're welcome that it's
the only someone like c-3po would take
that as a compliment I speak Indy nails
well thank you um Robert August saan
Robert Robert Roberts a good name in
short versus long for Bobby and Bobby
yeah does he call it a bother you does
he call it a Bobby you know I'm talking
I don't want to know that mom it's her
brother she wants to hear this I know he
doesn't you didn't he where is this is
Bobby's head nur ah God my ears
how's a guy ever said can I get a head
nurse sorry my last name is Han hand
gesture oh yeah get a lot of that
I'll ask them not really thinking very
thousand thanks for sticking around this
woman go to the real reject you loved it
when life hands you Morgan hand jobs on
Instagram we heading her on Instagram
how tears and Morgan and Ashley on the
YouTube check it out take care folks